well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire lovely to see both
of you welcome
i know you threw with us until midnight
as well or just before so let's check
out the front pages then the financial
times leading with the passage of the
government's proposal to spend 12
billion pounds on health and social care
funded by an increase to national
insurance contributions the guardian
also leading with social care investment
adding experts believe the funding will
not fix the crisis
the social care bill
comes as the telegraph reports the nhs
plans to recruit 42 new executives on
salaries of up to 270 000 pounds each
prompting questions about health service
spending
the metro dubs the education secretary
gavin the gaffe after he claimed he'd
spoken to footballer marcus rashford on
a zoom call when in fact it was rugby
player maro itachi both sportsmen
happened to be black the eye hears that
covert booster jabs could be offered to
as many as 35 million people and that
the effort could be finished by
christmas according to the daily mail
victims of police failings have called
on the head of the met police named
cressida dick to resign
and the express leads on a fresh
crackdown on migrants crossing the
channel suggesting they'll be turned
back to france if caught crossing
illegally
french anger adds the times who are also
leading on the home secretary's decision
on channel crossings and the star leads
on geronimo the alpaca as the debate
continues over his bovine tuberculosis
diagnosis before he was killed
so andrew ps kevin mcguire are here and
uh the the post-vote reflections on the
spending on health and social care um
fascinating do you not think andrew in
this topsy-turvy world we're living in
that tories have voted for tax increases
and labor has voted against health
spending
you could hardly make it up could you
and um boris johnson i know when he had
a private meeting with tory mps tonight
insisted that the tory party is still a
party of low taxation um but look
the world has changed completely when
the tory party elected boris johnson as
leader they pretty much knew he wasn't
margaret thatcher or
cast in the mould of margaret thatcher
when he was
mayor of london for instance he
supported an amnesty for illegal
migrants that's not a policy you would
ever have found a hard-line prime
minister like thatcher supporting but
he's he's he's he defies gravity all the
time as lord adonis who was tony blair's
head of uh policy uh wrote today in
prospect magazine the left underestimate
boris at their peril all the time i
think he's got this threat deal through
the commons
a very limited tory rebellion probably
the usual suspects were the ones who
were opposing it and you've got labour
mps trooping through division lobbies to
oppose a 36 billion pound boost to
health spending now kevin will say oh
well it's because of the way that the
money was being raised can say what he
likes the optic is appalling for the
labor party and the tories will make hay
with it yeah just quickly on that before
we get to some of the detail labor has
just handed a future election doorstep
gold plate to the tories and marched to
the center ground does it matter for
them kevin do you think
look you'd have to be at the optics in a
pub
drinking spirits to think that labor
voted against the increase in spending
labor voted against the increase in
national insurance which is the
unfairest way
of raising money capital gains tax labor
hasn't spelled it out there's a hole in
the labor position there but they kind
of hinted that against tax would have
been far fairer if you're going to raise
this money not national insurance which
means very low paid workers will be
taxed to protect the inheritances in
tunbridge wells parts of surrey of
people who've uh got huge assets and and
want to keep them and as the guardian
shows there the 12 million gamble will
will not fix care crisis
they some people are involved in it most
of the money raised will go to the nhs
there's only about just under 6 billion
of the 36 billion in the first three
years going to go to social care some
people will still have to sell
their houses the floor
has gone down from 23 000 to 20 thousand
so before you've got free care if you
had in england uh assets of uh twenty
three thousand now it's down to twenty
thousand
i think i think andrew's here but the
daily mail is going to be spending the
next year or so
finding the flaws in the policy he's now
uh converted to as he applauds higher
taxes on workers taxes he would have
opposed as as a tax on jobs if it was
proposed by labour yeah and that's funny
let me tell you go on there i'll just
say on this
because the job of opposition is not
just to oppose is to come up with
constructive alternatives and and kevin
said there's a hole here they didn't say
we
raised the money through capital gains
no they had no policy at all and when
liz kendall who is labour's shadow uh
who's in charge of social care for the
labour front bench was asked on the bbc
radio what what is your view what would
you do three times she was unable to say
they've been kirsten has been opposition
leader now for 15 16 months this policy
could have been they could have had to
quote a cliche they could have another
red policy kevin which could have
embarrassed the government but as usual
star has been found wanting and the
irony is liz kendall in 2018 signed a
letter supporting
support to increasing
social care by raising guess what
national insurance
i'll join in the criticism of kia
stammer and labour for not having a
fully worked out policy but uh beginning
of the weekend you were opposing the
national insurance increases
you've changed in 48 hours you've gone
from a pose
i mean that is quite a change mate that
isn't quite just
can i just andrew can i just ask you on
the specific specifics even of the 86
000 cap on lifetime care costs that is
care it's not accommodation which could
be half the bill so you're looking at
doubling that and that's at local
authority rates which is subsidized and
it's not the rate that private residents
pay uh so if you want a better room
nearer to home that doesn't it's not
included either people will be selling
their home left right and centers we
heard from multiple mps today this is
funding people in the southeast whose
properties cost a fortune well
my problem with the package is uh as
kevin identified most of it's going to
sort out the nhs which is very important
although i i in the past spending vast
sums of money on the nhs doesn't seem to
improve weightiness a lot of it gets
gets spent on the wrong sort of thing
yeah well let's see the television story
in an ideal world i would not have
wanted national insurance to rise to
support uh the
getting waiting lists down and to start
to get to grips with social care but at
least we've got a prime minister who's
had a stab at it and had a go at it the
first time this was raised was by tony
blair he set up a royal commission in
1997 he did nothing about it nor did
brown nor did cameron and theresa may's
policy had to be abandoned two weeks
after she launched it during the
election campaign no it's not ideal i'd
much remember there was some form of
insurance scheme but i still think that
could happen
yeah you can have it you can have an
insurance scheme to top up uh to to get
you to the uh to the 86 000 i suppose
yeah so we kept them quickly yeah
no it's a tax rise in search of a policy
we're gonna have to see how it worked
out there is no fully fledged well
worked out well thought out doing what
boris johnson says policy it just
doesn't exist he always just flies by
the the fans and he's gambling with tax
rises with those already
announced on income tax players by uh
freezing the uh the thresholds the
allowances and the increasing
corporation tax which are back of six
percent that's coming those combined tax
rises are something north of 30 billion
pounds he's gambling on losing his
reputation for the tories as a low tax
party it was never true anyway but he's
gone now at the highest tax tick for 70
years on somehow doing in labor by
saying he's going to fund the nhs and so
labour at the next next election can't
say look you you need to vote for us to
save the nhs he wants to say he's saving
the nhs taking a a colossal gamble but
let's not fall for speed about having a
fully fledged uh social care policy it
just ain't there yes well of course
boris johnson told the 1922 committee
that the tories were still a party of
low taxation this evening which is
with the 70 years the record-breaking 70
years feels a bit strange but anyway
just very quickly i'm going to show you
the daily telegraph which we saw
the nhs they say is hiring an army of 42
new executives on salaries that beat the
prime minister's more than 9 million
pounds will be spent employing dozens of
chief executives uh raising questions
about how the extra money will be spent
but i want to move on if you don't mind
to the eye which many people are
wondering about boosters to be wrapped
up by christmas 35 million uh the
boosters for people could start in the
next fortnight are we expecting an
announcement soon then andrew
yeah i mean it's it's got to go through
the uh jcbi that there's the committee
of government scientists and they they
do seem to be dragging their heels but
every minister i've spoken to is pretty
confident that whatever they they say uh
the government has been making a
decision that we will get boosted
but there will be a surge in infections
for sure
schools have gone back that would
they'll be a lag before those infections
come through we saw what happened in
scotland a huge increase in infections
so um why not start giving boosters to
older people people with underlying
health issues people over the age of 65
will all be in line for a booster so
kevin will be getting his booster quite
quickly not made just for a few years
yet of course but i think people will be
really pleased to hear this because the
whole vaccination program seems to have
gone off the rails a bit this will get
it all going again and i think it will
it will be good for confidence because
we don't want people getting nervous and
wary thinking is my second jab efficacy
beginning to wear off um i won't go out
i won't go to the theater i won't spend
money we've got to get this economy
going and booster jabs is a really
important way to boost confidence i mean
the thing is do you put all your eggs in
the vaccine basket if you put if you
look at the metro with the crowded
platforms the crush hour the paper says
journeys on rail and road bounce back as
the uk returns to work you see the
commons the cheering unmasked cheering
in the house of commons um is it time to
realize that you know there is still a
place for mitigations as we roll into
the school's return autumn winter
pressure and not just rely on boosters
kevin
i would have thought so that's a picture
at clatton
junction and that is incredibly 7 45
yesterday and you know the house of
commons where we're going most days just
about every restriction
is gone whether that's wise or not well
there's a there's a there's a big debate
uh
around that but as as you said it looks
like all the eggs are now in the
vaccination
um basket and that's 35 million the the
i say the government thinks it can
it can give us through the nhs by
december the gsevi i think it meets
tomorrow hasn't hasn't decided yet
whether it thinks uh booster jobs are
worthwhile i remember it
came out against them for for kids aged
12 to 15 because i didn't think the
medical impact would be particularly
significant to to justify there are
other issues around it and the
government hopes to um get the cheap
four chief medical officers across the
uk to agree so it has some scientific um
backing but following the science is is
very very loose now so much of it is
about uh public opinion and i think most
of public opinion people want a booster
job whatever the medical impact of it
they will feel safer with it but if they
feel safer with it and there are very
very few mitigating factors in in place
now then does that mean people will just
become blase complacent and we mustn't
forget we haven't beaten this virus yet
i think looking at the figures today 191
deaths the weak on weak figure is up
let's go to the metro gavin the gaffe
take it away andrew
well he's a complete idiot we've always
known that he should be fired because
he's been so incompetent two years of
chaos in exams and now he tells the
evening standard he'd had a very nice
conversation on zoom with marcus
rashford the incredibly popular
manchester united footballer who
humiliated him not once but twice on
free school meals except it wasn't
marcus rashford his team had to point
out it's actually maro itaji the rugby
player the connection between the two
they're both black he's had to issue a
groveling apology good god it's
humiliating it has to be the final straw
kevin yeah they can't let him out can
they they thought they'd give an
interview show him nice and uh and
reasonable and somehow he can recover
his reputation he can't he's just got
that touch where he gets everything
wrong and
because they are both black you can't
you you can't uh
you can't
miss what that might uh might mean but
look he's got two incredibly famous
people here it's not as if he's thought
about mr smith in blackbird and getting
him confused with you know mus wood in
burnley these are two incredibly
prominent people he is utterly utterly
useless as an education so kids deserve
to do so
um very quickly let's try and squeeze
two stories in just very quickly the
daily mail front page andrew if you can
really significant um that we now know
that crested the metropolitan police
commissioner is perversely to be given a
two-year extension to her contract even
though she's utterly incompetent the
mayor has put together the most
extraordinary panel on the front page
it's the widow of leon britain at lady
britain uh the mother of stephen
lawrence inside it's the family of lord
brahma family of sarah everard all these
people who've been victims of
metropolitan police
stupidity and ignorance it's an
extraordinary story and they're all
saying she must not be given an
extension she's utterly useless she's
never run a police force before she's
never been a detective she only got the
job because she was a woman and here
you've got two very different women on
the front page of the mail along with a
lot of people inside the paper saying
she's got to go
you've got text
yeah i don't accept she got that you
only got the job because of a woman but
pretty patella home secretary sadiq khan
the mayor of london have to justify why
they have given her another two years
okay uh we were going to do emma
radukana as well great success a
qualifier 18 years old uh historic in
that respect no qualifiers got through
to that level uh and we will talk about
that another time kevin andrew lovely to
see everybody thank you very much indeed